president rodrigo duterte wasn't seen in
public
for almost two weeks that fueled
speculation here that the health of the
76 year old leader
who says he hasn't been vaccinated
against covid19
is declining and his administration has
been hiding
his real condition his allies have
released
videos of him playing golf riding a
motorcycle
[Music]
and jogging at night in the grounds of
the presidential palace
but it was not enough to appease
skeptics
the videos have instead turned into
viral memes
mocking a president they say disappeared
during a time of crisis
his spokesperson says the accusations
are malicious
but is rejecting calls to release the
president's medical reports
on monday duterte resumed his weekly
address
dismissing what he called rumors and
attacking a political opponent
who's been in prison for several years
that's all i need
i just want to to ride linaman
and to ride at two o'clock in the
morning that is not taking the people's
time
i enjoy my
hobbies critics say the president's
behavior over the last few months has
gone from strange
to jarring that kind of absence without
leave on the part of the president since
he likes to
couch things in war-like terms if it
were a shooting war
that would really be abandonment of of
duty and we see the effects on our
people now
his government is facing widespread
criticism over rising numbers of covet
cases
and delays in the country's vaccine roll
out the philippines is also facing its
worst economic recession in years
with millions more filipinos made
jobless
by the pandemic there's also the
standoff between the philippines and
beijing over
china's military buildup at the whitson
reef in the south china sea
he's not spoken publicly against china
over its occupation of the reef
for several weeks since the pandemic
broke out
the president's movements have been
greatly restricted
his appearance reduced mostly to his
weekly public
address to contain his possible exposure
to coronavirus
but critics say they need not just
assurance of the president's health
but also his ability to lead during a
time
of crisis jamella allendogen al jazeera
manila